- Well it is Motivational Monday
here on the show,
and I love how you motivate women.
You really get behind them,
and want 'em to feel
(audience applauding)
good in their skin.
You think it's a really,
really important thing.
I love doing that as well.
Like was it always so natural for you?
- No.
Absolutely not.
I was a short, chubby, brown,
you know, daughter of immigrants.
Very little money.
Like dreaming of being in
the entertainment industry.
And everyone around me was like,
"What's your back-up plan
'cause that sounds crazy."
- People used to ask me all the time
and it made me so angry.
- Yeah.
Yeah, and so, you know,
the very first movie I
ever did was a movie called
"Real Women Have Curves"
and I was 17.
(audience applauding)
- Yes. (clapping)
- You know, I had to play this girl.
I had to take my clothes-
I had to be in my bra and underwear
and dance on camera.
I had to play this character
with so much confidence
about her body,
and I could act it, but you know-
People watched that movie
and gained so much confidence watching it
and felt so represented,
but at the same time,
I was just a 17-year-old girl
kind of coming to terms
with my own body image.
- Yeah.
- And so that was hard
but I feel like ultimately,
I'm now in an amazing place
where my relationship
to my body is about celebration
and not about punishment.
I trained for triathlons
(Kelly gasps)
starting in 2016,
and so when I got pregnant,
I was like in "triathlon shape"
or whatever.
I was very strong and healthy.
And then I had a baby,
and you know, my body can
do both of those things.
I can train for a triathlon
and my body shows up for
me in the ways I ask it to,
and it created life
and brought this baby into the world
and fed this baby, you know.
And to mourn
one past version of my body
versus celebrating what it is now
and what it did, what it did for me,
what it did for my son,
would be a shame.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I'm sure my body will look
like a hundred other things
in the course of my lifetime
- Girl, me too. (laughs)
- By now, I'm just
committed to loving my body
and being so grateful to
be in it every single day.
- That's so-
That's a great attitude. (claps)